you ready now okay okay once again
everybody welcome to you know your
favorite podcast what's the call okay
this is singer Mike I always opposite a
guest you don't know how old he is
what's his race you have no idea why is
he talking to a [ __ ] this week I like
the singing Mike that was great I was
like produced everything know about it
man that felt like Al Green was bringing
me on the podcast that was great
I know was that thank you and everybody
thanks to my guest this week this is mr.
Brad Williams yeah thank you so much for
having me thank you are you comfortable
cuz you look like you're not comfortable
but is that just like a switch I'm
always moving I don't look comfortable
cuz my feets don't touch the ground in
the chair okay I don't know why I said
that like Cosby but please don't touch
the ground in the chair no uh but no but
my legs don't touch the ground the
chairs so they're constantly moving
right yeah that is kind of weird yeah
I've never seen your legs like that
before so cuz you always see me standing
there were a little they're a little
hairy too I didn't even I got here's
everything
maybe bust out the feet cuz the feet are
definitely Hobbit feet like that
you have hair on your feet yes I do look
at I have hair on my toes yeah so do I
just like this it's like I'm in mid
werewolf transform and it's like it's
you're in that scene where like he's
turning into werewolves and all of a
sudden like the moon went behind the
cloud and I have to be like this I
always feel like I'm in that position
right you're right in the position where
you look at all the people not turning
into werewolf and go get away from me
that's exactly what you're right in that
position this Run For Your Lives I've
shaved this yeah but it just it grows
back even more so it's kind of a
nightmare and listen I always have to
tell the guests because I thought I had
this figured out but like it I know it
sounds like there's an echo but it's
actually a Pro Logic X thing that I'm
getting some kind of double monitoring
way above my pay grade okay but when it
when it don't worry when it comes out
you know the carrot this is just
uncomfortable when we're filming but you
kind of get used to it but I don't want
you to think like it's gonna be on the
thing now you shave to say this you you
shaved your knuckle hair my most
embarrassing like I'm getting older
thing is I've recently had to start
tweezing my ear hair oh you're tweezing
it yeah what you mean your wife is
tweezing it I mean yeah that's why you
get married just for that I'm also gonna
light a candle from hangover candle
company to use under breath yeah so
you're tweezing your ears just right
inside the ear like and not a lot of
hair just like one will be like you know
what's frustrating it's like frustrating
as you get older you don't even realize
you have those kind of problems like I
didn't know until like I was at the
barber you know and then the guy was
like you only get these ear hairs yeah
but yeah yeah the Barbican looks to you
like hey this so randomness on the back
your neck I'm gonna clean this [ __ ] up
you're like oh yeah actually I hate that
so much because like I dye my hair has
sometimes you know like half the time
but like I don't dyed to the point where
I have to keep it up you know I
die than and let it goes out so you know
yeah cuz I kinda like the the blend I
like having a little some great pepper
though on your neck mmm the neck hairs
just Gras like your [ __ ] Moses yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm always having to be
like oh can you clean this up yeah yeah
yeah this has been neck hair chat with
American bread the hot the hottest new
podcast on iTunes neck hair chat for men
over 35 tell me though like you know you
know it's like this is a weird thing
because it's like we don't know how long
we've known each other we've known each
other for so many years I know your
guys's you and Adam Ray's podcast you
enter of quick fat no that was that was
his thing well it was his thing you made
famous here on the episode worked where
quick fat which is for those who did not
listen those episodes that's a reference
to Adam because Adam was a fat kid but
so fat yeah but so fast yeah you so he
was ill he was an athletic fat kid yeah
but like I said known you for so long
but it's like you know are we said like
we know each other but we don't really
know each other let's get in deeper
first of all there are you from I'm from
Orange County California I'm an OC boy
so I grew up here I didn't have to have
that moment which I'm always in awe of
comics that and anyone really that has
had to have the moment where like they
live in Indy and they're like okay yeah
let's go to LA and my dream like I never
had to do that like while I was working
on my dream you know I can still go get
my laundry done in my mom's house right
no it was very much an advantage in that
way me too I know exactly what you're
saying yeah did you why'd you grow up I
grew up in LA yeah I'm saying I was a la
boy - yeah now the question everybody
wants to know is hey Peter Dinklage of
course one is career yeah do you have
your own great career I don't know it's
the thing where it's like he's just
better at maybe better than me even at
everything like like see I'm worried
that someone's gonna whisper in his ear
like hey Peter you should do stand-up
cuz he'll be like yes no no I will no
even worse he's gonna start our podcast
Dinkin with Dinklage
dropping dimes with Dinklage he's gonna
be doing like fantasy football reports
oh god he's just better but do you think
that is that like a thing though that
like when you're you know what's it
what's your proper term that we should
call you your dwarf comic what's your
pronoun
little person yeah I say I say little
person dwarf [ __ ] I say all three of
them most midgets don't like being
called midgets so you don't say that but
when did that start when was it like I
was always told like have you ever been
told something as a kid and then you
grew up thinking it and then you got to
be an adult and you're like oh but why
is that like yes I was told that but why
I feel like tall white people made that
choice for you yeah like well and you
know what I mean maybe that's what
happened because there there's a group
called LPA and that's little people
America and that's what it's kind of
like our our little social network and
it's been going for a while that's like
snazzy about that name yes when the
group was founded uh-huh it was called
midgets of America so for me it's like
dude you can't be like we're the midgets
of America you're the midgets of America
you can't say that word you know it's
like I don't get that cuz there's
already Mall of America so it's kind of
like our to be a kiosk just right next
door
we're just selling I those cases it's
kind of ironic that the biggest mall in
America is gone
MOA yeah the littlest people in it so
there's no like you I wish there was
like a story you could be like you know
there's like a guy he's like you know
you know served something something he
decided at night yeah right right yeah
yeah yeah well no let it be said so let
it be done and yeah not like a big
rubber stamp it just looked really big
in his hand yeah you know and then got
it notarized or whatever but yeah I
don't know where the whole [ __ ] is
offensive thing got started I don't know
when it was decided and I've never had
anyone really explain it to me to work
because like there's other slurs out
there that like you hear where they came
from you're like oh that's horrible
yeah I get it why that word means
something bad because it's in reference
to this thing no one
ever given me that good explanation
about the word [ __ ] where it works
like like someone said that PT Barnum
kind of made it popular talk about Tom
Thumb but I don't know that's not to me
like oh that's so funny are you like up
on all the little people like you know
is it like I know is Billy Barty what
are you about Billy Barty's son yeah
well it's like I kind of have to because
for a lot of people I'm the reference
I'm there I'm there dwarf Appiah like
where they can just like website dwarf a
PD accom where they where they could
just like look at me be like hey so
what's up with Verne Troyer like and
then I get like oh here's the ears burn
he's a he's dead but he's a different
kind of little person than me but this
is my kind of dwarfism this dispossessed
I don't necessarily want to talk about
that all the time
I'm okay with it but it's like the the
baby elephant in the room but at least
see here's the thing it at least you did
it in the form of a joke so like you you
went like hey you hate Peter Dinklage
right like no it was that I did a you
know cuz when we go on the road we
always have to do those like Dom morning
we wake up with Cleveland we got the
worst shows what are the worst [ __ ]
about it right now they must be terrible
with you yo it's awful cuz they just
look at the bio and that's it general
condition I ate some expired milk and
then this trunk down yeah but like so I
was getting ready to do one of those
shows and I look and I peeked over at
the lady's card that has all the
questions and the topics just so she
doesn't get lost and all it said was
Peter Dinklage not like about Peter
Dinklage not what do you think about it
yes Peter Dinklage game so I looked at
that I saw that was like okay so don't
let you talk and as soon as they win
alright good appearing this weekend at
the whatever funny bone it's Brad
Williams
I just Brinkley I just went in yeah talk
jokes talked about the weather guy how
he [ __ ] up and like put the but and
then did the whole segment like she
barely said anything
yes sometimes you have to do that or
anything over to me anytime they go to
your bio when they start talking to your
bio is when I want to take over I start
asking them questions I said please
don't ask me are you gonna ask me like
oh you see you quit you quit your job in
blah blah blah it's like that's all you
care about the same thing yeah freaking
talk but I guess that's just and I guess
they have a lot going on so they can't
do you know they can't like walk Walter
Cronkite you and you like some in-depth
profiles they just like go to your
Wikipedia page or whatever the hell but
yeah so this has been well I guess it's
like you know so being like uh see first
of all I feel like the word dwarf is
worse than [ __ ] yeah a lot of people
do like because it's just cuz we've been
integrated with dwarf and like oh when
you play Golden Axe you could be the
Barbarian the wizard or the dwarf right
so it or like Snow White in the Seven
Dwarves
it seems very fantasy no that's not a
real thing that's not what we actually
call them that's not no that's like a
fantasy thing it's like no I mean
technically I have a condor plastic
dwarfism so right it's like the medical
term Wow
yeah and it's weird because like because
like you say it doesn't sound right but
then you know it is yeah yeah if you say
little person it's just like that's
condescending it's boxy how man it's
just a little person like a person not
quite a person one little but I think is
worse when somebody's just short oh yeah
you know I mean I've talked to short
comics about this and may look at me
like dude you're so lucky tax breaks
yeah yeah yeah parking is like I'm four
foot four like and it's like alright
there is a medical term for me I have a
condition if you're a full-grown adult
male and you're like 5 - yeah it's just
bad man like and that's weird that I
look at you and go that's like like
you're in some weird in-between phantom
zone where like you're not accepted by
either culture I know when you're like
five - yeah you're like blade you know
yeah the reverse bleed you have none of
their strengths and all of their weak
no parking none of that you know big ass
what's funny about you is like yeah you
baby do got back see ya before you got
me excuse me Mary how long you been
married two years you've been made two
years but before that I really honestly
got sick of seeing you out places with
tall hot ass women yeah that was stolen
I'm just gonna honest I remember I saw
you one time at the Third Street
Promenade shoot just bad chick and I was
like what the [ __ ] is going on there's a
website you can rent them no no here
here's what it is and it was I
definitely have like that little man
syndrome where like Napoleon complex
parts of your personality is strong yeah
and I want to show everyone like oh you
think I'm only gonna be with like okay
because like Oh with his [ __ ] you know
like like I I feel like there's a lot of
fat guys that want to be with like that
hot thing yeah woman that's what I'm
with a hot thin woman there you go it's
what you want like we all want it but
there's a little extra because it's like
you're overcoming something and you're
proving it to people you know what by
the way it didn't work for me until I
just didn't care anymore and it just
like I just I just had full full
confidence and my value yeah and that's
when I started like going out with like
it was crazy
oh yeah no it didn't yeah it didn't
start with me until I started like
headlining cuz then I had the confidence
to be like yeah I'm good yeah I'm fine
like you should want to be with me you
know right well yeah there was a time
and now it's so weird to think about
those days now because it's just now
it's like just not now let me ask you
were you meeting chicks on the Internet
are you just walking up the chicks and
going like this yo girl come yet they're
so non threatened they're just like oh
my god you're adorable yeah yeah you
started giving them that man [ __ ] and
they were like oh what's so exciting
buddy's a man feeling something
so like he's a dude but if I want to
leave I can like cuz he's not gonna be
like hold me down yeah I gave me lady
know you're staying here like that's not
happening so I'm gonna turn you down
yeah I forgot how loud okay you got it
sit for a little man but big boys boys
you're like I like keeping that kind of
stuff in no but so that so that
definitely happened and then just as you
I mean you've known as you go onstage
and you become it's amazing how many
people and we don't realize this because
we do this for a living how many people
can't talk right right it's getting
worse because of like everyone's
communicating with text social media and
stuff where people like don't know how
to communicate like have you ever met
someone where it's like when you're
texting with them it's flowing it's good
it's like oh jokes jokes jokes and and
then you talk with them you're like oh
you're not even the same person whatever
text guy you're not we can't hang well
that's just like people on the Internet
then you talk a bunch of [ __ ] you know
they then they're just like even even
when you challenge them on the Internet
yeah they'll be like well I didn't know
you were gonna respond dude that so many
times
what are you Tony you're a big fan yeah
yeah now so so you saw what you were
doing is you is you were just saying
some insulting [ __ ] to get to get
attention
yeah yeah I know it's just weird but
like okay so let me ask you about this
then so you know it's like all right so
I'm a mixed race comic chubby guy right
now and sure that you know so like when
I'm on stage it's like that's one of the
things that's my thing
you know so I don't ever talk about I
don't like I'm not one of these comedy
and nothing to have anything wrong with
this but I'm not one this guy was like
oh I'm half this and I'm half that so
that means I could steal and I get that
you know he makes great comic ass so I
don't really like I love my talk about
it even people ask me they ask me and I
just say you know it doesn't matter yeah
I get how that's like a thing so that
been something for you this whole time
doing stand-up I was like it's like it's
not like you could just walk on you know
you can't just waddle on stage and then
be like and I never mentioned it people
you not even Gosei me does he know this
just happened to him today is not a real
where ya know that and if you read if
you read like YouTube comments and like
hateful comments the vast majority of
them are are just say something like
he's sure we get it and I'm like okay
there's more there's multiple layers to
that where it's like yes I cannot just
go onstage and just not mention it at
all it's also who I am I don't know how
to write jokes from the perspective of a
5 foot eight 5 or 10 or observational
yeah I don't know I've never lived in
life you talk yeah and also like it's
also something that it's really hard for
me to not mention something if literally
I'm reminded about it every 10 seconds
whether it be online whether it be out
just walking around in someone stares
some kid says some [ __ ] some adults say
some [ __ ] like it's hard to be like oh
so just ignore that thing that everyone
reminds me about whenever I go in the
morning radio show or a podcast yeah
like do you think the host is just like
so basketballs back let's talk about
like like they're not it should be yeah
don't and now don't get me wrong I'm
getting more and more to that point
because now yes yeah now I have actual
fans that I've seen me two three four
times so now I can move on and not just
like went because I had lunch with a
comic Euler day that saw my acting goes
you're really like not talking about
morphism all that much anymore I go yeah
because I did two audio albums and two
showtime specials and pretty much those
were the vast majority of them were all
dwarf jokes so it's like I'm covered
I've hit everything I guess you know I
guess you don't necessarily have to yeah
what it is I'm just curious for you do
you sure so you're feeling less pressure
now too much you have to talk about it
yeah I mean and don't get me wrong this
is still the little person experience is
still an experience that not a lot of
people know
now let people understand so they are
curious about it like and there's not a
lot of things where it's like okay and
so like if a black comet goes onstage
and says oh you know I got stopped by
the cops like we all kind of know that
stereotype already like we know that
like you say like oh I'm Mexican we go
okay so these stereotypes like we don't
necessarily have that for little people
oh the stereotypes aren't real first of
all like the stereotypes for us or like
we live in a tree and we make cookies
and we're Willy Wonka it's like oh but
where's the real one yeah where's the
one where it's like I don't know what
they are I mean for me big-ass like
that'sthat's mine and I know that's the
second time I mentioned it so I'm really
trying to call Tenjin Temma but but yeah
like that's that that would be one where
I'm like okay I'd like you gotyou you'd
have to go to physical characteristics
so I have so I have a kind of plastic
for for some big-ass collapsed nose
bridge large head average sized torso
tiny arms tiny legs like that would be
again and like you say when you say
wattle up to the stage I cut I kind of
want a little bit last cuz you get that
big fat ass yeah and like oh and here's
the thing achondroplastic dwarves like
myself we have a run too and we and it's
I didn't think I did the run anytime you
do videos like those slow-mo videos of
you trying to do anything that is my
[ __ ] I just love that one were you like
I was like yeah I was like just the way
you did it yeah well I was at the
Basketball Hall of Fame and they have
like a 10-foot rim an 8-foot rim a
6-foot rim and then all the way down
like a five-foot rim because they're
like well everyone could dunk on a
five-foot rim nope because all cuz also
my arms don't go like so when you see
LeBron just like throw his arm back and
come forward for like a tomahawk yeah so
it's like I can't palm it so I'm not
like doing that so like I act like no
you're not tomahawk Duncan is when you
saw
that's not in a repertoire here it was
so funny because I was on some podcast
or some radio show and I had mentioned
that I had tried out for my junior high
basketball team and the coach cut me cuz
obviously yeah and then that coach heard
that came to one of my shows and then
said I didn't cut you cuz you were a
dwarf I cut you because you're not a
good dribbler he's like he's like that's
why I'm like oh yeah I used to be a
basketball coach so I totally understand
like yeah I'd be like I'd cut you too
yeah yeah I mean like I can't cook you
know what you doing it's like anything
like if you would have been like we live
in a society now where they're like no
let him be on the team and like no
because if you can't succeed at it
yeah then your why you feel bad yeah why
should i why should I continue that
that's like marrying a girl that you
know you're gonna divorce it's like why
go down that road if you know it's not
gonna end well while I'm sure yeah but
like why yeah but why like tell the kid
like no you're good and it's like
nobodies ya know what I you know what I
learned
let me tell you how I learned that yeah
like a real-world example of learning
that yeah so again so I was coach I
there was just one kid I put on the team
mmm you know he was terrible yeah now
later like years later he's out of high
school okay and we just had one a
conversation he comes right to an alumni
that whatever he's talking to me he goes
let me ask you something why'd you put
me on a team he goes I know I sucked hmm
and I was like well everybody was
pulling for you and all this yeah he
goes yeah but when you put me on the
team I felt I deserved it and when I
wasn't playing mmm it made me feel like
well why am I not on a court I made the
team I never did it again after that
yeah people out here these [ __ ] with
their like everybody deserves a medal
and right
you know Sports is a pure thing it bring
us you know and it's like I should have
after that I was like if you deserve it
you gonna be on a team yeah tryout you
earn it you gonna be on the team if you
don't earn it you're not gonna be on the
team that's very that's what I love
about sports is that it is the closest
thing we have like you don't get to make
the Lakers because LeBron James is your
dad
right like you have to actually be good
and actually they even the small
nepotism that there might be sure that
person still has to prove them you know
absolutely like know you like they're
like there's plenty of jobs that you
that you can have because your dad runs
the company but no one no one looks at
Steph Curry and goes oh he's only there
cuz Dell curry is his dad exact nobody
looks no one thinks of no he's so much
better than his dad in threes is like oh
that's why he's there because he's doing
that so that that's why I love sports
cop comedy is is is is close but see
here's the here's I would say it's not
as close as what it should be exactly
here's the difference is that someone
looks at Kawhi Leonard do some [ __ ] no
barely anyone looks at him and goes I
can do that right promise stand up is
when we're good at it our job is to make
the whole audience go oh yeah I could
well here's the thing too though but
even okay on that same money on that
same logic line that was like I think
that in our business what's happening is
there are people in the NBA and I'm
people outside of the NBA
yeah there's Benchwarmers there's people
that aren't as good as quite Leonard yet
who are in the NBA going man I should be
starting yeah that's what's happening in
comedy business I see so like so there's
like these like would be comics who are
looking at the lineups and they're like
you know why am I not on this line I bow
my big the biggest one I can't stand as
I were through any women how come you
know women on the line up like at the
Comedy Store a lot how does that make
you feel because I always think it's
funny to meet it like if some woman's
going to you and going like like hey oh
my God look at this it's all men there's
all men Brad yeah we like you like uh
to counter Little Boots yeah now get out
the Dwarfs one around the country doing
stand-up money Vicki in and the the
question is always alright who do you
take off do you take off Marc Maron do
you take off Sebastian yeah yeah Ron
White and who do you replace them with
now if you're saying like oh I'm
replacing if your play if you're saying
like so and so with iliza shlesinger
it's like great she's killing it awesome
she's she's amazing and it's really like
I feel bad for Adam who makes the
lineups at the Comedy Store because he
has to do this dance that's so difficult
well that's like all right so you have
to have the so if you look at the comic
store lineup the first spot is usually
like someone who works there door person
or just got passed or like whatever then
it start then into us like one or two
like I don't want to say lower-level
headliners but like you like that
they're not selling out theaters let's
just say that like they're doing clubs
great and then it goes to like four or
five monsters that's when you get your
Rogan Segura's or Diaz your cry sure is
your your Liza's all that and then after
that it goes back to like the
lower-level headliners that are like
doing clubs and in doing well and then
you have to have four or four or five
spots that are just okay so you just got
in and they're family yeah you don't
have a huge following but we want to get
you some stage time you know if that
even stuff even has to do it I don't I
don't I don't necessarily agree with
your assessment of how they do the
lineup I don't know I don't really agree
with that assessment in terms of that I
just think it's like you know you put
your time in whatever it is you're
dealing and like you know he has to
think you're funny you have to have a
good response on the crowd along with
some of those things but all I'm saying
though is that like I can't stand this
whole idea that like you know cuz like
the women that can be on the lineup or
on the lineup yeah okay are great yeah
you know Wendy Cummings Mickey Ali Wong
iliza shlesinger letter man all the
people that should be on the lineup are
on the line and Laura bytes is getting a
ton of spots right now and she's killing
it Morales like there's so many but the
problem is like most comic look like
majority of comedies are not funny yeah
you know this is why the carny store
lineup is pretty it stays steady because
we're looking for people that could do
that right so a majority of comics or
men mm-hmm so we're just saying is that
the percentage of not funny too funny is
pretty high right so therefore there's
less women in comedy so a lot of them
are not gonna be funny yeah it's just
that's just how it goes if there's let's
say there's and this is not obviously a
science I'm Louie just coming over these
numbers but it let's say there's a
hundred male comics yeah and let's say
let's say 10% of comics are funny yeah
and that's pretty high
that means there's 20 funny comics in
that in that 110 10 percent you see 10%
yeah so that oh yeah so that yeah sorry
I can't do math so that yes so that
would mean there's 10 funny comics out
of it yes so there's 90 unfunny comics
ups deserve to be on alone so now and I
would say like for every 100 male comics
there's 10 female comic right so only
the less one of them is funny let's say
two of them are funny yeah and that's if
they're doing the map the same manner
and and that that's not to say women are
not funny cuz cuz obviously there's
enough women that are hilarious to prove
that women are funny it's just that your
numbers go you know what I've been and I
feel bad for them too because I know
that it's harder to break in it is
they're not getting the same
opportunities and so what I what I've
done is I do a show at the lab and it's
a Hollywood improv do it once a month
yeah Eric and Friends yeah it's not as
big as Joe Rogan and Friends every other
month I would do like Eric and his
female friends yeah you know and then or
if I even if I do Erica friends I try to
make sure it's like 50/50 because like I
took
I'm hearing it yeah I go okay so you're
not getting opportunities I don't all
right I'm a male comic who has a little
bit of influence yeah
two clubs I can be like alright so cuz I
feel like I had just check on the other
their name cherry cola never met her
before I don't never met her before she
just hit me up randomly on say hey can I
do your show and I was like you know
what you don't realize is like if your
fear female comic you in LA you ask me
do the show okay okay good it's hard to
find female right just recycling the
same us anyway she was killing the other
night like I was like wow this chicks
really funny so I do understand so that
I have taken my part to be like alright
I'm gonna take it upon myself to like to
help because but but it's like because I
go because I can't stand when I look at
the comic store lineup and then some
like idiot from the internet it's like
oh there's no women I go they take
another look at the lineup it's still
mostly white yeah so don't take away
from what I had to do to struggle yeah
to get to the spot that I'm at while I'm
in the lineup and it's like Chris D'Elia
Joe Rogan's in me yeah okay so I had to
work my ass I'm not gonna get it taken
away because somebody who's like didn't
you go through what I went through or
isn't as good yes you go take my spot
away because fur to fill a quota yes
lock you and that in and that's the
other thing when when you say how hard
it is for having to make a lineup he's
gonna make a lineup every night
based on who's in town I know that's a
great be alright you got your white man
you got your women you got your black
comics okay can we throw an Asian on
there Brad's in town alright [ __ ] poor
just like he's trying to like make
everybody happy
okay is Robin training okay transgender
comic oh like like you're just throwing
up everybody just a Martin el gay comic
pen like he's trying to check all the
boxes and there's only so many spots to
check the box and I hate the box
checking I just wish it was more like
sports yeah I wish it was more of a
meritocracy but it's just not yeah and
that's a hard that's a hard thing to
realize and I and here's the thing I
know that as as a little person comic
I'm aware that maybe I've been given
some opportunities because I'm a little
person I'm I'm totally aware of that but
at the same time I then had to be funny
to continuously get the door open is one
thing that's pain inside
do we eat now when you look at like you
know cuz I know I do this
mm-hmm I mad you this is who I am I look
at you know I'll go out for an audition
and then I said don't get to part then I
look at that thing and I go this
[ __ ] got it you know I recently
had one of those moments
yeah I'm saying so it's like yeah
because like I this is so weird because
I already feel like there's not enough
parts for me yeah so I can't even
imagine Oh bro do you know how mad I was
that I went that I wasn't a little
[ __ ] in choker oh yeah I know and I
auditioned for that role oh man I was so
mad that it's like sometimes someone
does a performance and you're like oh
that's what they were looking for I
definitely did not do that
gosh okay I get it and I don't want to
take anything away from this actor
because that's I want to take money out
of someone's pocket and he almost
ashamed he did a great job but I was
looking at like I [ __ ] didn't do
anything like I did that you know what
it is only one spot yes I'm saying it's
almost got to get it and got it and who
and who knows that was such a great
scene it was like it's such a great I
read it so I knew it was coming it was
like so hot so I was like watching it
like didn't even I didn't laugh some
people laughed but I didn't laugh I was
terrified
oh as a [ __ ] I am terrified of that
scene I was - oh that's true - cuz it
yeah yeah I'm like is that where you go
with bread that's like that's like a
dwarf Horror Story oh the calls are
coming from inside the house you get it
so you can leave but now you can't leave
cuz it's locked
you can't reach the look what dump that
was so great what'd you think of the
Joker loved it yeah I thought it was
great loved it here here's my thing
about that movie is like how long let's
talk about every other depiction of the
Joker was like and don't be wrong I love
all the depictions of the Joker stirred
a little but like I you know what by the
way different let's differ how about to
say let's go back to before you go on
yeah could you finish I want to talk
about sure sure sure
you trash Jared Leto but I think he
Joker ratings yeah yeah what's to our
Joker rankings oh sure I dude I did a
tweet about this and it got like oh
let's do it you got
more retweets than whatever so uh my
thing about Joker movie is that this was
like the first time every other
depiction of Joker he was this
fantastical evil like was crazy like you
know like a comic a comic-book villain
right wait were you like and always he
always fell in a vat of chemicals so we
always gave him that excuse that it's
the chemicals that [ __ ] with him
yeah and then this was the first
depiction of the Joker we're out we're
out where I was like oh yeah this could
happen like this could like I know
people I know things I know some people
learn by the way those dress by the ways
this has happened you know it's like
Edie Kemper and like all these serial
killers that they do putting on these
shows and like you know Manson and like
you know so they're those are are those
are our real life Joker's yeah yeah no
totally okay so here are my personal
Joker rankings and this was in a tweet
no number one for me is still Heath
Ledger
I thought Heath Ledger's why God cuz on
the page it said here we go
Heath Ledger did that and went okay and
then made it and here we go
and yet did and that's just one example
but he did that whole character he
created that whole character and did it
in a way that we had not seen before
like you could argue that maybe in The
Killing Joke that the the actual comic
book The Killing Joke right like that's
where we saw that kind of version of the
Joker but he made it so dark and he was
one of the first ones to actually do it
that way right like I'm like bro that's
the Nolan I think Nolan yeah we invented
this so yeah them but that version of
the Joker to me is still is still my
favorite and also these are my personal
Joker rankings yeah but by the way this
isn't Rolling Stone two hundred best
singers going no Bob Dylan number seven
Whitney Houston number thirty seven shut
the [ __ ] up and that and that's how it
is
no no if I may sure I I think that
they're on par with each other too
because I'm sure your number two is
gonna be where I came Feeny it is
okay so my read my reasoning for them
being like 1a 1b yeah it's because of
what they had to work with I would love
to see Heath Ledger doing a rated R
version yeah because I was pg-13 and he
still found a way to be like you know
and they still had to tone that back
yeah they had to tone it back so even so
so I don't know what would he have been
too much
rated R I don't know so I don't know so
maybe the tone back is what kind of
helped it be so terrifying exactly it
you didn't see and then maybe if he
would have had free rein yeah maybe it
would have been too much who knows so
number three and this is this for some
people why did you like Joaquin Phoenix
go to Homer to Yonkers just because of
the realism of just the you played this
and I saw in Joaquin Phoenix a guy you
saw the torment you saw what led to it
because it's like when you're watching
like the the backstory of Darth Vader
you go the [ __ ] does a guy get to be
that evil right and then I was kind of
disappointed with all the things that
happen to me oh don't make him you know
you had a bad day that's not that's not
it so yeah you don't go you don't go
from like one second you're a hero and
then you're killing kids yeah you're
like putting kids in five minutes later
yeah that was the worst run bro you know
but like you saw him he's got the shitty
life he he faint he fantasizes he
projects and then the life doesn't
happen and he every now and then he gets
a break and then he doesn't and he gets
made fun of and he's got this
conditioning like and anything he's got
and he's got mental illness and all
those things and you saw it build the
system failed him
yes you know that's another thing so
he's like nice element to it right to
where he you you you didn't see him
being evil to hurt people you saw him
being evil to hurt the system yeah you'd
be like no I'm burning the system down
like this and I loved it I forget so
like when I say he didn't even want came
for me yeah I guess for me it's kind of
like what you said like a 1 a 1 be like
they're just just because they were so
because they again they were just
different films different genres
and this is one that got me a lot of
heat when I put this one at number three
uh-huh
mark hamill oh I totally if you're gonna
go actually I mean there does an
argument for him being number one yeah
cuz that cuz that voice yeah yeah he's
the quintessential Joker character
that's the Joker voice and he created
that that was not given to him that was
not being like hey do a voice that's he
goes Joker hmm how'd he sound boom and
just seems great and hits that voice
whether it be in Batman the Animated
Series a couple of animated movies the
Batman games he was the voice in those
two and it's just he's kraler so I
actually have no problem with him any
numbers yeah another jack let's assume
is number four no he's not oh not for me
who's number four then Cesar Romero oh
okay so you just you got camp all in the
middle yeah okay that's from my
childhood yeah and like I really like
Batman 66 I'm not mad at it when I was
growing up lady - you're a kid yeah
someone's like you didn't even shave off
his mustache for the white makeup I
don't give a [ __ ]
I didn't write I never noticed so we got
high definition go back yeah I didn't
noticed that [ __ ] as a kid it that that
Joker to me was the exact Joker I needed
as a five year old and a six year old to
get me into Batman like it was that it's
that fun it's that campy it's that dude
this is cool like like totally polar
opposites of like them yeah yeah yeah
yeah cuz you can't you can't show
Joaquin Phoenix to a four year old and
be like that's jokey but you need a
Cesar Romero to to get people into it
five is jack and that hurts me because I
love Jack I love Jack as the Joker I
know but that particular see I'm not I
said I'm not necessarily a fan of that
Batman but of those like Batman so you
don't even have Jared Leto on the list
it's just top five no I had him on the
list in my tweet his number 627 why I
take umbrage with that but I project I
thought Jack Nicholson was I thought he
added some
credibility hmm to that movie but it
still was like in the sort of cartoony
campy world like it's in between a
cartoon and that man begins yes terms of
like the the tone yeah they were still
Batman was still wearing a cow that
didn't allow his head to turn around
right and then they went on like that
then they went off the rails all the way
up to the frickin line or Schwarzenegger
doctor friends and all those were all
terrible but ok so Jared Leto got a lot
of slack okay but personally I feel like
if Heath Ledger performance did not
exist yes I think the Jarrett little one
would have been like later I really like
that it's just hard to write when you
have that and the guy died and he one
writer when you follow yeah guy yeah
you know it's like it's like all right
like we like let's say so when let's
pick your when Tom Brady retires I know
in 15 years
it's gonna be hard for whoever does God
like you gotta follow the guy you know
the standard is you have to be Tom
[ __ ] Brady I know that's hard but I
think why I the problem is that movie
was bad that too
okay so the movie was bad so then even
whatever performance he could have given
to it it was out of place in that
terrible movie yeah and I mean yeah but
like I always thought that like like I
always thought that if they needed to
bring somebody to be I get into Nolan
ones and I know you Heath Ledger died
and I think it ruined the whole series
yeah cuz they probably would have done
joke to it something different one no
but I thought I always thought the one
person that could have done it would
have been Leonardo DiCaprio mmm yeah
that's in he's in the nolan universe yes
you know i thought he was so so when
joaquin phoenix up the thing i was like
oh wow that's gonna be I felt like he
was gonna be good yeah but don't like I
said I've talked about this already I'll
talk about it with you is like my one
problem okay my one problem with the
movie Joker with the movie joke okay
he's too old yeah he's he's 40 but yeah
even evilest age 40 and he in Cameron's
10 yeah okay
so into 30 cuz they
25 years he becomes Batman this
[ __ ] gonna be 70 yeah man Joker
yeah and like you're still fighting with
thats gonna be grandpa Joker yeah I just
don't I didn't I heard somebody say a
theory that oh no that's not the Joker
that Batman actually fights that's the
Joker that inspires the real the real
Joker it's like okay standalone movie
they're not making another exactly so I
can suspend my disbelief for that note
see the thing is we know there's three
superheroes yeah three that we know
though that the average person knows
their origin story okay number one
Superman
yeah we know Superman came from Krypton
he lived on a farm in Kansas yeah okay
he became Clark Kent we got it yep the
second one is Batman yep I mean that
Batman story people know Bruce Wayne's
parents for killer then that makes him
hate all criminals and be like file
closed after that is spider-man
yeah people know that story too was
great power comes great responsibility
yeah he got bit by a spider yeah so we
know those origin stories right all
right but it's like so it's so it's hard
to like look at Joker and try to ignore
the news like no you got we know you
just had an interaction as a 45 year old
man with the 10 year old Bruce Wayne
wait [ __ ] so he so he's gonna even 15
years conservatively he's 25 year old
Batman you're now you're now 60 you're
like you're like 55 yeah but then you
think about it you think about like but
then like even then like then do you
think and you think of Nicholson right
he was an older guy yeah picture Batman
but [ __ ] Batman was old at first
Batman Keaton was like 35 40 yeah that
wasn't with that I never liked him as
Batman if I had to rank my Batman whoo
Batman rankings yeah we get you got your
back man rankings off the top of your
head the top of my head Wow like I mean
and here's the thing it's hot I know it
is hard yeah I wanna say Christian Bale
right but then the voice was a little
weird it was weird and he anyone he's
talking to people that he knows
and who knows he is Batman he still in
the voice okay somebody's listening yeah
even when like he experiences pain he's
always like like you're like dude really
gonna grunt cuz I cuz I'm sorry if I'm
doing like if I'm doing like an improv
scene and I got a deal like a British
accent or something yeah something falls
on my toe I'm not going oh [ __ ] by the
Joker well okay so then if we had to
like okay then I'm not gonna say Kevin
Connolly might be my number one I'm not
gonna who was that the voice of Batman
well just got the voice the first guy
that go I am the night I am Batman
well okay no no but there's a scene in
Batman cuddly or Conroy [ __ ] there's a
scene in Batman Begins that like the
best scene of Batman Begins
and as when you know the Commissioner
Gordon at the end of the movie and
Commissioner Gordon says like I never
thank you and he goes and you'll never
have to but I'll say this though I think
that back I think Christian Bale in
Batman Begins is the best man heaven
Conroy not Kevin Connolly Kevin Connolly
is Ephrem entourage I'm sorry
save your tweets sorry I just wanna make
sure it's a hard choice because you have
to think about how good the product is
the overall movie that this is yeah and
then you have to think about you have to
weigh it because I am partial to I
really like to Ben Affleck as Batman
I did too I wasn't mad at it and I
talked about this with a Bobby's brother
I thought that that Batman fight in
Superman Batman when he was going to
rescue to mom right that was the best
Batman [ __ ] ever cuz they they modeled
it like after the videogame yes that he
was so good the disrupter yeah Batarang
yeah
the grappling hook of rolling on there
rolling into the next guy always think
don't but see the only thing I was I
didn't like about that Batman is bad I
wouldn't kill people Batman Batman
that's his whole mantras so it's not
like he's gonna be a hero that's like
that yeah and that's just bad filmmaking
they didn't lazy they did it no no they
just didn't they didn't set up mmm
enough will you believe Batman went over
the edge
yeah they didn't set that up enough by
the way how many women do you think are
still listening to the park we've gone
off it's already 95% 5% weight it's
hilarious do you think you are look at
this bit this is like the weirdest cop
show on Fox in C it's funny cuz in order
like to go back to your argument like
you have to consider the whole movie and
like were they actually good but the
movie was bad yeah that was letõs
problem like I might put Val Kilmer up
pretty high bro we're wow we're on the
same page I actually liked I was out
Kilmer too but the problem is that was a
terrible movie yeah like you want to do
Jim Carrey was serviceable but he's been
better at that point he was campy at
that point Tommy Lee Jones was terrible
like that was just a terrible millat was
such plant I do agree with you I thought
Val Kilmer did a pretty good you think
you pick I think we could pick the worst
Batman's before we could pick the best
yeah you know yeah just throw Clooney
yeah let's go out why don't we tell more
we should go see movies George Killeen
was terrible yeah but but that wasn't
even his shoemaker yeah Joel Schumacher
Schumacher whatever my one of my
favorite moments from because I saw I
saw Batman and Robin that's the Clooney
one one one one of my favorite is in the
opening scene when they're doing the
thing with mr. freeze and he's making
all the ice puns
one is when he goes like activate bat
skates and then like the ice skates come
out of his feet and then not like ten
seconds afterward you see a shot of them
going through and they're wearing
rollerblades yeah
now that was one of my favorite parts of
that movie and then also when Alicia
Silverstone is doing like the bike race
their spark cannons
there's just cannons like oh she went
over a jump so POW like Pyrrha did you
think that they're doing an illegal
street race doing they're like hold on
we can't start the race yet do we have
pyro yet like they're setting a pyro
just a street race it's just the worst
that was one of the worst the worst of
the superhero movies so works but that's
in the ranks of like I've said the worst
superhero movies pure that's in there
yeah yeah I liked Kilmer I like Bale I
liked I liked Affleck I like Adam West
because for the same reasons we it's a
campy it's good it's fun like I like I
like Kevin Conroy Shep Conroy Kevin
Conroy voice you know it's so being a
nerd and a you know and a dwarf is it
like this is a go hand-in-hand
I don't know I mean that's the thing I
don't think it does but there's like for
you though I'm I'm a little bit in like
my I like to think that as a comic I
know a little bit about everything I
don't know a lot about any one subject
but I know a little bit about everything
I can hang in like most so you want to
talk about nerd culture cool I got some
opinions on that now it helps to
actually really like that [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know if we talk about sports okay I
got that like you know I mean like I got
the different hats I can wear and it
because you want to be able to go in any
situation and be able to talk about
something and when you look at some of
the audience you go hey what do you do
for a living and they say like oh I'm a
whatever I'm a psychiatrist I'm a
veterinarian I'm a what you go oh okay I
know four things about that cool let's
go right like let's do a joke or learn
and stuff from people like yeah you know
oh
so something I was doing in my act for a
while I stopped doing it I should bring
it back is before I tell the story about
how my wife and I met I asked a couple
in the audience hey how'd you meet and
then I just listen to what they say and
like kind of make fun of it because
they're all absurd Leah like I don't
think there's you have a story that I
could just be like oh wow yeah I can't
really you know what's funny about that
you see it's weird you know you say that
it's like like I would say let's say 10
years ago yeah
10 years ago I think it was like all a
secret how people met yeah you know like
or some weird oh I got hooked up or this
person sent me but now it seemed and
then what then internet comes in and I
remember how was such a like a taboo to
be an online online now no one gives a
it's like we've been on Instagram well
we met on there right I met my
girlfriend on Instagram who we're back
together by the way oh yeah then I'll
ignore all the bad thing you know it's
so funny your wife so funny because your
wife was like that remember that one day
I saw her at the store yeah I'm the
store and she was all like
she was all like weird Rachel you know
like man you know we gotta put me over
we have a support group for she does fur
fur you know girlfriends and wives of
comics he does sounds like oh that's not
so interesting you know yeah and she was
like issues like yeah so tell her and
then I told her about it mm-hmm you know
I was like you know they had just a
program and she went like this oh my god
I need that
yeah cuz I want to ask them how do they
deal with like at the travel yeah and
the diva behavior thought about I was
like oh [ __ ] yeah I was like when you're
in entertainment yeah I don't care how
hot the girl is sure you you're the
focus yeah let me you know out there
right now it don't matter like when I
when I that's not men or that's both
yeah male oh yeah whoever the way it is
hard because cuz like you know she's
beautiful she models you used to get
a lot of attention rather we out in
public if people are coming over to us
life becomes just kind of weird it's
interaction and it's hard it's hard for
somebody who's like been you know you
know cater to just for me a beautiful
for a long time sure you know sure
that's a heart it's hard the economy I
was I was lucky enough and that my my
wife does not like the spotlight she
doesn't want to be in this place she
wants to be she wants to be behind the
scenes she wants to help yeah yeah she
loves helping I love the fact that you
guys are adorable together I really
found like a really good like in term
not just like the the person where you
go oh my god you you talk about checking
boxes yeah [ __ ] checks all the boxes
so I'm just so like yeah sure we fight
sometimes but I think that's natural but
then like you'd be it at the end of the
day I go yeah we had the little fight
about the dishes or whatever but then
while I was out doing podcast she got
all the merchandise ready to go on the
road that weekend we really fight about
the dishes ya know someone someone gave
me because I I was asking advice and
stuff like that about relationships with
a comedian couple that's been married a
really long time and one of the things I
said that would has been so helpful to
me is that when I'm gone and this is
gonna be even more so when there's a
child in the house which January 18th
we'll get into that really she poppin
she POW January 18 to having a baby girl
we'll get into that so like there is a
world there is an ecosystem that exists
without me on the road there is that
house functions in a certain way that he
has set up and it functions really well
right when I
I mean you must have a lot of ladders in
your house let's see I have to do mine
those library ladders right yeah just
slide them over
III have two major stools downstairs I
have three no two two upstairs and then
a big-ass ladder in the garage which
someone gave me as a wedding gift and I
wasn't even like hate no and I was like
thank you this will get used yeah but
yet but what I'm saying is like she
creates this perfect world for her and
then I come into that world when when
I'm home for three days
rough day now I want the world to be
catered to me yeah yeah and that's very
frustrating and but now that we know
that we can identify that be like okay
what do you need me to do and we have
this thing where we sit where we say to
each other like okay this is what I hope
to get from you today and she's like
okay and it's what I need from you today
and it could be simple things like tasks
and chores or to be like hey I need a
lot of compliments today I'm having a
load day I you say that yeah like I need
you to tell me right hey thank you thank
me for like you know providing oh I feel
you
do that for me today because I need that
today and should be like no problem I
got you or like you know she'll tell me
like hey I'm pregnant I'm yeah uh six
months pregnant like I'm feeling not
very pretty
tell me I look pretty today please I'll
be like no problem I got you like yeah
you know for you or like we you know
whatever things she organized I'll be
like I'm I'm itching on the inside right
now so your your wife's pregnant you're
not going I so like like what you you
know the burning question Oh
dwarf or not yeah yeah yeah we find out
in early what early November we haven't
done we have a doctor's appointment they
find out at 30 weeks and we're like oh
that's crazy that's crazy so is it like
that be hilarious if it was like that
yet to have like you know see like if
you didn't want to know anything so you
don't know if it's gonna be you gonna be
a blue or pink have to be really little
alright yeah we don't know how do you
feel about that are you like but what's
your real you know what I mean you don't
care because obviously I've loved it
I've delivered
yeah they're doing good things with like
it hasn't really I've only had one dwarf
related surgery a lot of us have
surgeries which is very unfortunate but
at the same time it will be difficult
for me if she is a little person knowing
that Oh like I did that to you like that
like anytime that she has any problem
anytime where it's like oh I have
surgery or this guy rejected me or this
guy or girl like only wanted me because
I'm a little person like that's gonna go
or like I had to do this right or I
couldn't go out for the sports team I'm
gonna go like that that part of its
gonna be really hard but overall I know
that she's gonna be great and loved
either way I loved like an insane amount
thanks for sharing that I'm all
emotional right now it's oh you should
have seen us when we went when we heard
the heartbeat for the very first time oh
just tears yeah I can imagine I can
imagine so
it's brain and she must be like
obviously she's okay with it or why was
she even yeah I've married you at the
first yeah exactly what she can't be mad
wow you have sex with a little person
yes so yeah it is it is a cool thing
where we were trying you know it's not
it it wasn't a surprise we were ready
but yeah what and for the comics that
don't have kids at all right now asking
me like hey what's it like and even
though she hasn't she's not born yet I
just don't know what it's like to like
have a pregnant wife and all that and I
go here's what it's like is when you
find out that your wife is pregnant or
your girl was pregnant whatever every
little problem that you had it just goes
away goes away you don't personal
problems or even issues that you had
both her oh well that's good to know
that it go and I I don't want to say
that as in like okay so if we're having
problems in the relationship I have a
kid it fixes everything
focus on those problems fix those first
but like all like if that's really more
a testament to your relationship with
her thank you and yeah it's like also
all that goes away and you're just like
okay now we have a focus now everything
becomes about this baby oh yeah has it
changed your work ethic are you like
thinking about now you're thinking about
this many world rotates you I have more
pressure obviously to earn more - at the
same time there's pressure to also be
home so you can so hard have those
moments so that's a difficult thing it's
like this is the life you chose you know
it's hard to be like well what you home
all the time because that's why the
lights are on
yeah oh this has gotta work yeah you
know these lights working
yeah doing nothing on a Tuesday yeah to
go like you know that was one of the
problems that I had is where we broke up
and now we're back so when things have
changed you know so we'll see but it's
just it's a tough balancing my wife
could be so happy to hear that you guys
are back together
she loved her yeah she's great she's a
doll
yeah it said it's a really interesting
thing and now like there's there now
there's our there's a nursery in the
house we're getting changing tables that
have a stairway on them so I can climb
up the changing table like that there's
like you're supposed to like there's a
chair where you sit with the baby and
like rocket and all that but like I
can't do that because my legs and touch
the ground so we got videogame chairs
oh wow so I can sit on the video game
chair and then my legs touch the ground
yeah there's all these little things
it's times like a show dwarf dad I mean
if I had no soul yeah I could totally
have a reality show and just a dwarf dad
but yeah you won't yeah you won't see
how to learn she's not gonna be on a
Learning Channel
no I'm not gonna be on the [ __ ] Club
show network by the way so I'm okay I
can't stand yeah like any Housewives
shows yeah me too could it's just women
being ratchet and like these men and the
men that have made horrible decisions
yeah and these relationships is so
telling we end
it's all it's all amped up because they
want to make a show so they throw the
worst parts of people and then right so
I said how can they make this better
mmm and they did they got little
housewife oh that's right
The Little Women shows a little bit and
I was like it's like I feel so guilty
when I watch these shows because they're
so like that the people they're so
terrible and then maybe they're not and
this just what they're showing for
payment purposes but like do you ever
look at something like that'd be like
how these [ __ ] are setting us back I
mean I look at it as hey we could be
ratchet hoes just like you tall people
God like that's fully whatever you
you're your best you know your [ __ ]
best actor cool Dinklage we got that you
know you like it now and now your worst
your ratchet ass how we got that to end
I don't I shouldn't say ratchet ass cuz
I've dated two of them but seem to know
so you just you just had like a wide net
range my shortest girlfriend was three
foot seven my tallest girlfriend was
five foot eleven right let me ask you
this I got in comparison sure like is is
like this I'm not trying to be like but
it's not you have you have you have me
here this is why you would like it what
like obviously you have your wife you
love your wife
okay all right so let's take her out of
the equation
yeah yeah but in your single years sure
so like sex with a dwarf mmm is that
easier to manage or do you did you enjoy
that just as much as you enjoyed like
you know have it to like tackle Mount
Everest you know what I or was it more
difficult for the tall girl or easier
like like what is the what are the pros
and cons of both sides
it's like I had fun and I hate this
because it sounds a good diplomatic
answer and I try to answer all questions
honestly but I really had great time
with both there wasn't like a thing
where you were like oh I have to go
through no it wasn't like a you just
know in that moment yeah it to me see
it's great oh good to know I will say
this about dwarf girls mm-hm is if I'm
with the tall woman
dead-ass huh if I'm gonna tall woman
uh-huh
if she's shaved that's cool right if I'm
with the dwarf woman can't be shaped
really for me because it they're tiny
tiny legs shaved but it reminds me too
much of a kid a little baby yeah and I
looked down there like oh no I can't do
this and I get it you want to be sexy
and all that [ __ ] just like everybody
else but in that moment for me I don't
look at someone and be like don't do
this you know I call preferences totally
yeah yeah and yeah so and now and now
and I've got to the point where I
actually like hair on whatever tall
short just doesn't even realize a lot of
times it's like their own projection you
know they're you know they're just like
I need to shave I need to do all these
things and I'm like fine give me with
your stank about that kind of pheromones
whatever it is like that but sure it's
interesting look dude I really
appreciate that like you're so open and
I'm actually glad you came on and had
this conversation
I actually want to bring you back
another time so we could like just
strictly talk about movies the whole
time let's do it let's do like a summer
movie preview yeah I would love to I
would love to do that with you
[ __ ] I'm gonna have all Brad's
information underneath
down here you have all this information
what you got going on tell me well here
you'll here's a big one is that Adam ray
and I we have the about last night
podcast but we're doing this for the
very first time we're doing a cruise oh
that's great we're doing a cruise last
night cruise yeah so it's so it's the
Adam and Brad spooktacular at sea
because it's happens it's happening
October 30th through November 2nd of
2020 so a year from now Wow year from
now go from Long Beach to Mexico uh-huh
we're gonna have shows we're gonna have
a live podcast when I have meet and
greets we're gonna have the goddamn
Comedy Jam come on karaoke I was just
trying to get invited it's so go to go
to travel by Parker dot-com well bye
listen you can I'm gonna get all this
information from you yeah we're gonna
put it all down over comm they'll be on
the cruise it's the same person that
does the Adam Carolla cruises so you'll
see his photo you'll see art you'll see
our photo and yet it'll just be a great
time it'll be like you're on a boat and
you
here's think it's Halloween weekend it's
gonna be crazy how many times do you
like do not make any Halloween plans and
all of a sudden it's Halloween you're
like oh [ __ ] I didn't think about it I
didn't do anything okay Holly's not even
a real holiday look you still got to go
to work tomorrow yeah it'll work on
Halloween yes so our thing is if if
you're one of those people that's like
you never make Halloween plans but you
want to do something fun boom
book your trip book your cabin done you
have your Halloween plans for next year
taking care of you're gonna be on a boat
going to Mexico with a Jew and a [ __ ]
come on there it is guys get and
actually Adam Ray's coming on in the
next couple weeks so I'm gonna have him
on to cuz I love the cruise she came on
when it wasn't like this okay hey mama
no I was like [ __ ] it was like
you know I said you got to come back and
do it right so yeah oh you got the brick
wall you got a fern yeah I got ya I got
my thing that tree other art over here
that I got to start putting out great
now but anyways guys this is Brad
Williams thanks for coming on dude 1
like I said thanks for sharing your Stu
your some personal things
congratulations on being a new dad thank
you and and then I wish you the best
either way no matter what happens either
way I think are you gonna manage that I
love your wife that's just going to
double you don't love to yeah that's
just set that up cuz we're gonna have a
we're not the kids soon cuz you do that
before yeah yeah we either gotta go out
or cuz once we have the kid I'm taking
three months off so like come over we'll
do that yeah that's not like a plan
once again guys I want to thank Brad
Williams for coming on and please
subscribe share go to go to all the
links and thanks for watching we're for
what Griffin and I'll see you next week
[Music]